it was meant to be the day they
announced whether this
the shuttling of negotiators between
london and brussels the endless talks in
nondescript rooms
might end we were told we might get
finality but no
perhaps hinting at a breakthrough more
talks i had a constructive and useful
phone call with prime minister boris
johnson despite the fact that deadlines
have been missed over and over
we both think that it is responsible
at this point in time to go the extra
mile
we have accordingly mandated our
negotiators to continue the talks
and to see whether no reach an agreement
can be reached
even at this late stage
and yet after speaking to her the prime
minister got on the phone to his cabinet
being more pessimistic
the most likely thing now is of course
that
uh we have to get ready for wto terms
australia
terms and don't forget everybody we've
made huge preparations for this we've
now been at this for
four and a half years sam you won't say
there's been political progress
from the eu but you won't say that there
hasn't been
what i'll say is i think that the uk
should continue to try
but no longer going backwards boris
johnson wouldn't say that
any progress had been made in the talks
but wouldn't rule it out
ursula vonderlion said the talks have
been constructive
but wouldn't say how welcome to
the brexit roller coaster where a
pessimistic anonymous statement from
number 10
can send the mood plunging and the other
side can say the talk's been useful
and worse momentum looks like they're
backing again
the only thing that is certain is that
the talks didn't stop when they might
have done
the opposition wanted deal well i think
everybody would have liked to have seen
a deal by now
but the very worst outcome would be to
crash out with no deal whatsoever on the
first of january
after all these months and months of
negotiations
perhaps there are optimistic signs but
number 10 won't agree
even in private with that so as of now
again we repeat there remains a path to
a deal
and a path to no deal and time is
ticking
sam coates sky news